>> Mark: CNN'S CHRIS CUOMO
WENT BALLISTIC AFTER BEING
CONFRONTED WHILE HE WAS OUT WITH
HIS FAMILY.
THE GUY APPARENTLY CALLED HIM
FREDO, A REFERENCE FROM THE
MOVIE THE GODFATHER.
CHECK OUT THIS CONFRONTATION.
>> I DO NOT INSULT YOU.
DO YOU WANT THAT TO BE HER
NICKNAME CUSTOMER >> I DIDN'T
CALL YOU THAT.
>> YOU CALLED ME FREDO.
DON'T BE A LIAR.
I WILL BLANK RUIN YOU.
>> WELL WHY DON'T YOU DO THAT?
>> Mark: CUOMO HAS SINCE
RESPONDED AND SAID THAT HE
MISSPOKE.
BUT HIS INTERPRETATION OF THE
WORD FREDO HAS APPARENTLY
CHANGED OVER THE YEARS.
HE IS OR WHAT HE SAID BACK IN
2010.
>> THERE'S A GROUP OF PEOPLE,
POLITICOS THAT THEY ALWAYS HINT
THAT THEY MIGHT RUN BUT DON'T
NECESSARILY PLUNGE ALL THE WAY.
THEY ARE MEMBERS OF.
>> Mark: CNN IS CREATING EVEN
MORE CONTROVERSY, CLAIMING THAT
FREDO IS AN ETHNIC SLUR.
>> KEPT FREDO BACK HOME, SO WHO
CARES WHAT DONALD TRUMP JR. SAY
SAYS.
>> THIS GUY, ON THESE DIFFERENT
OCCASIONS, BASICALLY TRIED TO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE.
>> NOBODY RESPECTED HIM ENOUGH
TO CARRY OUT HIS ORDERS.
>> Mark: YOU KNOW, GREG, WE
SHOULD ALL JUST ENJOYED THIS
STORY.
WHAT I ESPECIALLY LIKE ABOUT
THIS IS WHEN HE GOES STRAIGHT TO
THE F WORD.
HE ACTUALLY SAYS, "OH, BY THE
WAY I'M CHRIS CUOMO.
I HAVE A SHOW ON CNN.
AN   "
>> Greg: YOU DON'T WANT TO
BOTHER PEOPLE, BUT ALSO, DON'T
TURN THINGS INTO THINGS THAT ARE
NOT RACIST INTO THINGS THAT ARE.
NOR IS FAKE NEWS THE N-WORD FOR
JOURNALISM.
SOMETHING IN CUOMO'S BRAIN.
THAT'S THE N-WORD FOR ITALIANS.
IT'S SOMETHING THAT HE USES OVER
AND OVER AGAIN.
IT'S AN ANALOGY FOR HIS OWN
CLAIMS OF VICTIMHOOD.
THE GUY WHO WENT AFTER HIM IS
NOTHING LIKE ANTIFA.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS, I THINK HE
KNEW THIS WAS HAPPENING.
BUT I THINK THIS FEEDS INTO HIS,
I KNOW HIS REPUTATION AS A TOUGH
GUY.
A NETWORK THAT THROWS AROUND THE
H WORD.
HITLER.
EVERYBODY THAT WORKS HERE IS
SOMEHOW A WHITE SUPREMACIST,
ACCORDING TO CNN.
>> Mark: SO IF I FOLLOW THAT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Mark: THE VICTIMHOOD THING
IS THE MOST ABSURD THING ABOUT
THIS.
THE IDEA THAT FREDO.
>> IT'S NOT AN ATHLETIC SLUR.
IT IS NOT IN NICE.
I MEAN, YOU ARE BASICALLY
CALLING SOMEONE A LOSER.
SO IT'S NOT NICE.
I DO GET THOUGH, I MEAN, HE'S
OUT WITH HIS FAMILY AND HE'S
TRYING TO HAVE A DECENT TIME.
I THINK PEOPLE THAT NOW EXIST TO
EXCITE YOU, TO COME UP TO YOU,
TO AGGRAVATE YOU, TO DISRUPT
YOUR PEACE, TO RECORD YOU, TO
TRY TO CAPTURE SOME CRAZY THING
THAT THEY CAN THEN DISTRIBUTE ON
THE INTERNET, IT CAN BE
INFURIATING.
I HAVE MY OWN MOMENTS WHERE I
CAN BE OUT AND THAT CAN HAPPEN,
AND I MIGHT JUST START BLOWING
OFF STEAM IN THAT MOMENT.
SO I GET IT.
HE CAME ON AND SAID "I SHOULDN'T
HAVE REACTED THAT WAY.
I SHOULDN'T HAVE TAKEN THE
BAIT."
I DO GET THE ROOF FRUSTRATION OF
JUST EXISTS DOMINIC EXISTING IN
THE PUBLIC EYE.
>> Greg: DON'T GO OUT.
>> Mark: THERE IS NORMAL
SITUATIONS LIKE GO OFF THE
RAILS.
IF YOU ARE EATING AT A
RESTAURANT.
BUT YOU DON'T DO WHAT THIS GUY
DID.
THERE IS A COOL WAY TO REACT TO
THIS KIND OF THING, ISN'T THERE?
>> Juan: THERE IS.
I TEND TO WALK AWAY, BUT IT
HAPPENS, AND IT'S VERY
UNPLEASANT.
I'M SHAKEN BY THE IDEA THAT THIS
WAS RECORDED.
THIS INDICATES TO ME THAT IT WAS
A SET UP OF CHRIS CUOMO.
THE KIND OF RHETORIC THAT HE WAS
USING WAS INTENDED TO PROVOKE
CHRIS CUOMO.
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE SO
MANY PEOPLE STANDING UP FOR
CHRIS, INCLUDING PEOPLE ON THIS
CHANNEL.
I KNOW THAT THE PRESIDENT
DOESN'T LIKE HIM.
WHY ARE WE DEFENDING CHRIS CUOM
CUOMO?
I JUST WROTE ABOUT IT IN MY
COMMENTS.
SOME GUY COMES UP TO ME AND
STARTS USING OFFENSIVE WORDS AND
SAYS HE LIKES TROLLING ME AND HE
AND HIS BODY      BUDDIES.
HE ASKED FOR A SELFIE.
IT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S LIKE, YOU ASK ME, WHAT DO I
DO?
>> Greg: DO YOU THINK THE
COMPARISON IS FAIR THAT FREDO IS
THE N-WORD?
>> Juan: NO, I THINK THAT THIS
GUYS SET UP CHRIS CUOMO AND
CHRIS CUOMO FILE FOR THE BAIT.
APPARENTLY, I AM VERY
RECOGNIZABLE.
>> Mark: YOU KNOW WHAT I WOULD
LOVE TO SEE?
I WOULD LOVE TO SEE SOMEONE COME
UP TO DANA PERINO IN A
RESTAURANT AND FOR DANA TO
LAUNCH INTO A.
SOMEONE SHOULD SET THAT UP.
>> Dana: I AM SO
UNRECOGNIZABLE.
THIS DOESN'T HAPPEN.
WHEN YOU ARE OUTSIDE OF NEW YOR
NEW YORK.
YEARS AGO, I REMEMBER BEING
CALLED A WAR CRIMINAL.
>> Greg: I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT.
>> Dana: I FIND IT VERY
UNATTRACTIVE WHEN MEN DO THIS.
SUPER UNATTRACTIVE.
I ALSO FEEL LIKE BEING THE
WHITE HOUSE PRESS SECRETARY, YOU
NEVER, EVER LET THEM RATTLE YOU.
DO NOT LET THEM ROB YOU OF YOUR
DIGNITY.
BUT ALSO, YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
THAT THE CAMERAS ARE ALWAYS ON.
THERE'S THAT.
THE OTHER THING IS, I MET A
TOTAL LOSS.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
CONTROVERSY.
I NEVER SAW THE GODFATHER.
>> Mark: THAT'S HOW NICE SHE
IS.
BEFORE I CAN TESTIFY, SHE IS THE
NICEST.
>> Greg: C GODFATHER ONE AND
TWO.
>> Mark: I WAS WALKING DOWN
THE STREET WITH DON RUMSFELD
AFTER THE IRAQ WAR.
THERE WERE ALL THESE PEOPLE
YELLING "WAR CRIMINAL.
WAR CRIMINAL."